[Music]
over the last couple years progressive
web apps have revolutionized the way we
build products on the web but one of the
biggest limitations is that they're not
discoverable on the app stores
if you want to write your web code once
and then reuse it everywhere you'll most
likely use a framework like ionic to
wrap your code in a web view
but get ready to learn about an
interesting new alternative to this
approach
a trusted web activity if you're new
here like and subscribe and you can grab
the full source code on fire ship i o
and i'm giving away another t-shirt with
this video all you have to do is let me
know what you think about twas in the
comments below
first of all what is a trusted web
activity the short answer
is that it's just a way to run a website
in full screen mode within an android
package
you can already do this today and i'll
show you how to do it step by step in
this video we'll take the existing
fireship io pwa
package it up in android and then deploy
it to the google play store
before we get into that you might be
wondering whether you should build a
hybrid webview app or deploy as a twa
let's start by looking at some of the
advantages of a twa
first of all it's very easy and if you
have an existing pwa you can follow
along with this video and have it on
google play in the next few minutes and
unlike a web view it's not sandboxed so
you have access to all the features of a
pwa this means you can use things like
oauth and local storage without having
to patch in cordova plugins in other
words whatever works in your pwa
currently is going to work just as well
in this native app and your content will
always stay up to date so if you deploy
a new feature to your pwa it will
automatically be reflected in the native
app as well there are also some
drawbacks here as well for example this
is only for google play has nothing to
do with the apple app store
the next drawback is that there isn't a
plug-in ecosystem and you don't have
access to the native device features
so you need to rely 100 on the features
available to pwas
and lastly you need to comply with all
the policies for the google play store
so that could complicate things if you
have a payment system that would
otherwise require in-app purchases
so what's the bottom line here well if
you have a progressive web app and you
just want it packaged so it's
discoverable on the google play store
then a twa is something you should
definitely be looking into
and at this point i'd like to give a
huge shout out to zven budek he has a
great article on medium about setting up
a twa and if you're looking to hire
developer that's familiar with these
things you should definitely get in
contact with them
let's go ahead and release our own pwa
to the google play store in 12 easy
steps
step 1 build a progressive web app it's
beyond the scope of this video but your
app will need to at least be able to
produce the add to home screen button
which means that it registers a service
worker and caches your pages so they can
be viewed offline
frameworks like angular can do this for
you automatically or there's libraries
like workbox that can help you set up a
pwa in an existing website
open up your site in chrome and then run
an audit your production site should
produce a pwa score of 100 and a
performance score of 80 or better
step 2 install android studio you'll
need this on your local system to build
the actual apk that gets deployed to the
google play store
step 3 sign up for a developer account
on google play and fork over 25
you need a paid developer account to
create releases on google play
step 4 create an android app in this
demo we'll just clone an existing
android app that has already been set up
for a twa
you can find a link to that repo in the
main article and if you want a deep dive
for
everything that has to change in the
android application you can check out
this article from google but you don't
have to do everything from scratch
because the starter repo is already
available to you
after you clone the repo go ahead and
open it up in vs code or android studio
and then find the app build gradle file
step 5
update the app build gradle file with
your own information you'll see an
application id
as well as the manifest placeholders
array all you have to do is swap out
those values with your own information
step 6 open up android studio and create
a key store
a key store is used to sign your apk or
your android package
and it's also used to validate ownership
of your web content
trusted web activities only work with
first party content and that's a good
thing because that means somebody else
can't just go and grab your progressive
web app and wrap it in their own android
app
in android studio go to the build menu
and then select generate signed apk
this will give you the option to use an
existing key store or create a new one
let's go ahead and create a new one and
make sure that you fill out all the
fields here
and also make sure to remember the
password this will also generate an
actual keystore file on your system
so make sure to keep a reference of the
path to that file
step 7 create a digital asset link to
verify ownership of the web content
to verify ownership we'll use this
keystore that we just created
from the terminal we can run the key
tool command with the following options
and that will generate an sha 256
certificate fingerprint for this key
store
and google provides a little web app for
generating the content needed for the
digital asset link
just take the value of the sha-256 copy
it in here
and click generate statement that's
going to give us some json code that
will take back to our web application
and deploy to our web server go into
your progressive web app code
and then save this file in a location so
that it gets deployed to the path of dot
well known
slash asset links dot json on fire ship
io we use hugo
so we end up saving that in the static
directory but again that's completely
dependent on the front end framework
that you use
the only important thing is that this
file is accessible at the corresponding
url when you deploy your site
i'm deploying that to firebase hosting
of course and now we can move on to step
8 which is to generate a signed apk
we can go back to android studio and
click build generate signed apk
we'll select the apk option and then use
the keystore that we've already created
from there select release as the build
type and then also select both signature
versions down here at the bottom that
should generate an
apk file that you can find in the
releases directory
and that gives us the payload that we
can actually install on a user's android
device
step 9 go to the google play store and
create an application
from there go to app releases and create
an internal track
release this will allow you to privately
deploy your app to google play and then
distribute it to testers based on their
email addresses
go ahead and upload the apk and then
fill out any other required information
at this point you'll see an error that
says no internal testers are assigned
yet
this actually means that you just need
to fill out your google play listing
step 10 fill out the store listing the
content rating and the pricing details
until you have four green check marks on
the side navigation bar
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
step 11 finish the rollout process if
necessary and then you should see a
status of pending publication for your
app
this is the part where you have to wait
around for a couple hours and then
eventually it should flip to a status of
published from there you'll have an
opt-in url link that you can use to link
to the store listing and download the
app on your device if you're an approved
tester
step 12 log into your twitter account
and brag to all your friends about how
you're an android developer now
that took a bunch of small and easy
steps but overall i'm very excited about
the potential of twas
if you go all in on pwa technology it
gives you the closest path
to write once and run everywhere as long
as everywhere doesn't include ios i'm
going to go ahead and wrap things up
there if this video helped you please
like and subscribe and make sure to let
me know what you think about this
trusted web activity stuff thanks for
watching and i will talk to you soon
what do you this yeah you gotta have an
opinion